alors c'est un mec très chaud ce soir
tout ça y est je crois qu'à un mec est
dans un bar dont qui commence à boire
des coups avec le barman et tout
électriques complètement bourré le mec
et tout lui je te parie le mec comme
arles bourré il lui dit je te parie 20
euros que là je suis capable de mordre
mon oeil droit
mais lilibet je les prends de 20 euros
facilement et du mas d'azil série
servant aux mêmes stratégies vas-y vas-y
tu as parfois mon mec il enlève son oeil
comme ça est il mort son oeil reste un
oeil en vert erroné sont là et comme ça
va mal il s'est fait prendre 20 euros il
a merdé tout mais qu'ils regardent comme
ça ai dit je te parie 20 euros tout ce
que je suis capable de mort de mon oeil
gauche
il vient fasse pas possible il est pas
venu le mec si l aveugle c'est pas
possible et du asie j'ai récupéré mes
vent froid et vent mais qu'il enlève son
dentier
il mord son neveu il m'a eu l' hyper 40
euros et commence à être pas bien le
barman et où le mec qui voit qu'il n'est
pas bien et dit bon je te parie 40 euros
que je me mets à 3 mais tu prends un
verre un shooter comme ça et je pisse
dans shooter sans mettre une goutte à
côté ouais les mecs qui disent c'est
impossible c'est bon là je vais
récupérer mes quarante balais diot cac
40 va comme ça il prend un verre de
schutter le mec qui sema trois mètres
comme sait comment ça pisse et hippies
partout dans le bar partout il emmène
voudront s'unir partout là le barman il
rigole bien il prend les 40 euros comme
ça et tout et ils voient que le mec
rigole en phase iv pourquoi tu régale je
viens de te prendre 40 euros là il veut
ce que tu vois le mec qui au fond du bar
là bas j'ai parié 1000 euros avec lui
que si je pissais danton bart allez
rigoler
sur le fil qui a vu ses deux breaks ils
ont grandi ensemble dans le même
quartier
ils sont opposés de piles sont y en a
qui est pas le psg le pour marseille et
l'autre pour le barça pour le real ils
sont toujours en opposition
ils grandissent comme ça sont très
élevés et ronald qui dialoguent et
écoutent il dit écoute quand va mourir
au paradis roi du football
aniche pas franchement je sympathisais
ont fait un pacte celui qui meurt le
premier il vient dans le rêve de l'ôter
ludiciel du foot donc ça passe et un des
deux qui meurt gg humeur et bernard
geiger bon et il vient dans le rêve de
bernard est bien large alors rien du
foot il y met bien sûr que du foot
en plus ces paradis c'est assez limité
le temps et les stades ils sont grands
remplissez mortelle jeudi par contre tu
joues la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]